Well, good afternoon.
Can you hear me okay?
Well, that's good.
How are things with you today and this
week?
Oh, wow.
It's okay.
I mean, you don't always have to be
prepared.
Sometimes we're not prepared for things.
And I mean, we'll just continue onwards.
I did update the agenda with just some of
the answers we had put together and then
ultimately the questions that we haven't
gotten to yet.
So I think it'll be okay.
Nothing too taxing, let's say.
But yeah, that's a lot of lines of code,
for sure.
I've actually been sick.
I had a pretty bad cold on Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday.
And finally, my fever broke yesterday
evening.
So I'm feeling 100 times better today than
I did yesterday around this time.
So that's good news.
And other than that, no, nothing much
else.
Just working and trying to recuperate,
I guess, is my week in a nutshell.
So that's okay.
Yeah, no worries.
I love hearing the...
But yeah, nonetheless, I think that will
be fine.
Could have actually just used the link
that I... Oh, that's the wrong one.
Yes, this is wrong.
Probably.
We have a few different ones.
Yeah, this is it here.
Good.
Okay.
Okay, let's put this on this side.
Okay, wonderfully.
Let me increase the size a bit.
Too
big.
Okay, so I'd suggest, why don't we
continue onwards with the questions we
haven't gotten to?
And then ultimately, we can go back and
review sort of what we put together in
terms of what was written down.
It wasn't modified that much to a great
degree.
So we should be okay.
Also, on that side, too.
So I think we got to... I just want to
make sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So I got to number seven, problem solving.
Okay.
Okay, let's go.
Okay, so the next one focuses on more of
around operational aspects, right?
And this will probably come up in some of
the technical questions around having a
critical bug.
I know that you had mentioned before that
there wasn't really a critical defect that
you had encountered.
But I know that we had talked about this
before in previous lessons around concepts
about, you know, deploying, assessing the
criticality, like how much of an impact is
the defect?
And then the choice of whether to,
is there enough time to solve it?
Or do you need to roll back?
So that's really sort of how you want to
approach this approach to this answer.
Yeah, I'll ask it, and then maybe have a
think about it.
And then, you know, you can try to
summarize your thoughts.
So yeah, tell me about a critical bug
breached production.
Usually that's after post release.
And what immediate steps did you take?
Yeah.
That's okay.
Okay.
Yeah, so something like that.
So okay.
I wonder, yeah, I wonder if we,
yeah, so I think the best bet here would
ultimately be, I think ultimately the best
bet here would be describing the process
that you're fully aware of.
And then ultimately, I wonder if it's
smart to mention you've never gone through
such an occurrence.
It's very interesting.
You've never had like a high impact defect
in production in your entire career on any
application?
It's rare.
That's good, though, I mean, in a way.
But yeah, perhaps instead of saying,
unfortunately, it could be fortunately,
fortunately during my career, I have not
encountered such a scenario or,
yeah, it certainly can be stressful.
Yeah.
Maybe what we can conclude here is that
you have had production defects,
of course, but they were not critical path
enough to justify either a rollback or
some sort of critical focus, because they
were defects that were, you know,
inconvenient, but nothing that was causing
a substantial impact to a large user base
or, or, you know, the performance of the
environment.
So, of course, I have,
yeah.
Yeah.
So, okay.
We either had to apply a hot fix.
Yeah, that's or wait until the next
scheduled.
Yeah, that's certainly enough.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
So, I don't mind this at all.
Pretty good answer.
It's a quick.
Okay.
So, this is quite an important one as
well, especially when you're like a tech
lead, and it's a large, larger size team,
multiple applications, multiple things
going on.
So, we're going to want to think about how
you put this answer together, and I can
provide some guidance.
So, excuse me.
So, the question being is, how do you
prioritize your daily work when you have
multiple urging bug fixes and new feature
deadlines at the same time?
So, really, the answer has to be not about
the what, you know, whether it's defects,
enhancements, internal, external,
client focused.
The important part is, how do you manage
prioritization of work?
So, there's a couple things to consider.
One is that features already could have
had a priority associated to it.
Defects, priorities, product roadmaps.
The other is that there are activities
that have similar priorities, but they
haven't been completely ranked.
So, you may actually have to describe what
would you do in that situation.
If you have three or four things that are
almost the same priority, but aren't,
but it's not clearly defined.
So, then you have to have, you discuss
what's called the prioritization.
Meaning, you use a priority framework like
RICE, right?
Like a priority framework like RICE.
This determines
features and defects.
Yeah.
So, if you look at, there are numerous,
there are numerous priority frameworks.
If you look at RICE, and there's others,
there are quite a number.
If you look here, prioritization method.
Where did that graphic go?
Such a nice graphic.
Here you go.
I'll put it right in there.
Yeah.
So, you can see.
So, this is always something that you
don't, you can always refer to the
framework, even if you haven't used it.
But just so you can get comfortable with
it.
So, typically, what would happen in this
scenario is you have all the stakeholders
together, usually a representative from
product, from business, from engineering,
and probably customer success that
represents the client.
And ultimately, you have RICE.
So, a couple of the frameworks only have
three metrics.
Some have four.
It doesn't really matter what it's called.
RICE is the easiest one to remember.
The world needs RICE.
I suppose it's easy to remember.
But it's reach, meaning the size,
right?
Like, how many does, you know,
user community size.
The impact.
So, impact being, you know, is it
affecting a drastic amount of individuals?
Is it having a negative perception to your
customer base?
Is it creating negative social media?
Is it impacting your users, preventing
people from purchasing things?
So, impact is ultimately very important.
Confidence.
Confidence is just, it's just that.
How much do you, how confident are you in
fixing or finalizing, finishing the said
feature or defect in a certain amount of
time that's been
estimated?
And then, lastly, is effort.
So, what's the effort to actually get this
done?
So, what basically, yeah.
So, basically, you add it up in the score
that gets the highest from all the
stakeholders.
Basically, that's the, that is priority
number one.
And that's what the engineering team would
work on, regardless if it's internal,
external, client-focused.
Yeah.
Yeah, and it's officially used
internationally or globally, probably
including in your neck of the woods.
So, it's a product framework, but it's
very client-focused.
You know, usually, by definition,
client work takes precedence over
everything.
You know, if customers are suffering,
you know, that's the highest impact,
of course.
But not always the case.
It could be that you have to get a product
out as soon as possible because you're
falling behind in market share.
You don't do something soon, you're going
to not exist as a company, right?
So, yeah.
Just something to determine, which is
interesting.
Okay.
So, yeah.
Why don't we, yeah.
Sure.
In our, sorry?
Yeah, you could just say simply,
like, you know, I'm used to some priority
methodologies like RICE, and there's many.
So, you can just drop that subtle hint
around RICE and you don't have to go into
the detail of it, but just say,
you know, you're used to priority meetings
and all of those aspects, which is
actually interesting.
So, yeah.
Okay.
So, usually, the priority is identified by
the product managers and or team leads.
You could put maybe stakeholders and
stakeholders.
As an engineer, we can usually follow the
values that are set in terms of what gets
addressed first.
However, if it is not, we have our own
responsibility to verify the priority of
competing activities using priority
methodologies like RICE, for instance.
Yeah.
Maybe something like having an established
process and, yeah.
So, like, um, by having an established
process and methodologies in place,
you know, we usually can identify
activities to be done relatively quickly
without introducing delay.
Maybe something like that.
Yeah.
So, by using such methodologies and having
established processes in place,
we can extract business values and impact
from the current situation
and identify as many priorities as we can.
Good.
That's not bad.
Have a read.
Yeah.
I like the answer.
Good.
Keep that pretty picture.
Wow.
It's evening, buddy, not morning.
Some of the chickens here are so mentally
kind of rooster.
It's getting dark.
It's supposed to be.
Did you know?
I had no idea.
I'm from Canada.
Actually, this is a really funny story.
Did you have any idea that roosters and
chickens, if they don't have, like,
a chicken house, like a chicken coop,
we call it, they sleep in trees.
I had no idea that chickens sleep in trees
or on branches and things like that.
I just thought they hid in some bush.
No, I had no idea they actually tried to
jump and fly into trees.
Usually, they go to sleep right around six
o'clock.
So, bizarre.
Yeah.
Of course.
That's funny.
Yeah, yeah, and they actually try to go
pretty high up in the tree, so they can't
get predators, right?
So, it's not like they're only,
like, five, you know, three, four,
or five meters above the ground.
They go pretty high into the tree and,
you know, try to hide or blend in when
it's dark.
And they always start going into the tree
just as the sun is going down.
So, it's quite intriguing.
I had no idea.
I'd never seen it before.
Yeah, quite funny.
Yeah, can you imagine?
We're talking about tech and software
development and then how a rooster gets
into a tree.
Yeah, they try to get onto the roof and
then do running jumps.
They don't like to stay on the roof.
They somehow get onto a level and then
they try to fly and get to a branch and do
all that kind of stuff.
So, it's fun.
Yeah, so.
Okay, well, the next one.
More about leadership and mentoring.
So, I know that you've mentioned this
quite a bit.
Have you ever had to mentor a junior
engineer or onboard a new developer to
your team?
And how do you normally approach it?
Yeah.
So,
Okay, well, let's think of this.
Let's think of this in a higher use of
English.
So, okay.
So, you've confirmed you have experience
and, you know, you consider it a fortunate
experience that you've mentored.
And it includes when you mentor,
it includes onboarding new employees or
new developers into your team.
So, how do you do that?
Well, one is you introduce documentation
and material.
That's self-evident.
But more importantly, how do you mentor?
How do you train?
How do you teach?
So, it's those words.
So, let's start off with during my career,
I was fortunate enough to mentor and
onboard a new developer in our team.
During the onboarding process,
our team has put together a lot of
detailed documentation about our platform,
products, and technical tools that allow
the colleague to become self-sufficient,
something like that, or independent.
To become independent, we can put pins on
the word you like, independent.
So, yeah.
And so, what does mentoring mean to you?
Mentoring means teaching, right?
Teaching, guiding, reviewing.
So, you want to give a lot of detail here.
This is what a true leader is,
right?
Whether you're a manager or whether you're
leading a technical team and focusing on
tech.
Whether it's things like job shadow,
whether it's that you have the buddy
system where you bring them to client
meetings on complex projects, whether you
assign them technical tasks and they
follow a principal developer, intermediate
developer, or whether it's a combination.
So, how do you teach?
Okay.
Yeah.
So, let's not get out.
Let's try to reset here for a minute,
right?
Because the question talks about a junior
engineer, someone who's a newbie outside
of school.
So, you're kind of describing someone
who's a seasoned professional and you
would help them with the onboarding
process.
We want to do, even if it's a fictitious
story, whether it's not completely true.
You want to be able to communicate or
describe some of your training methods.
And the training methods can be,
you know, what's done around the world,
really.
You know, you assign a junior engineer to
job shadow with one of your senior
engineers.
So, they learn about your platform,
your tools, and just overall how a project
is working or how the initiative is in
progress.
Another one, of course, is job shadowing.
You know, they go for buddy-buddy.
You know, the junior engineer can approach
anyone in the team, but they have a SPOC,
a single point of contact, at least to
start off with, for a certain amount of
time.
You're giving the example of code reviews,
right?
So, when it's a junior engineer,
you typically, of course, would spend a
little bit more time reviewing their work.
And if there was some challenges,
you would have a technical conversation on
how they can improve certain technical
activities in a positive way.
That's kind of how you describe it,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
And then, sorry, what were you going to
say?
So, it would allow us to provide some…
Okay.
…in order to ensure clarity and
understanding.
Something like that.
So, we can… Oh, I got to get rid of this.
Okay, so that's probably not too bad of a
starting point.
Yeah.
Okay.
I like this question.
Adoption and growth.
Tell me about a time you had to learn a
new framework, library, or tool quickly
for a project or some initiative.
And it can definitely be a story.
Tell me about a time.
Once upon a time in a faraway land,
there was a Kazistani senior professional
named Andrew who came down from the
mountains and learned technology.
Right?
It was a hot summer day, and the sun had
not come through because it was so smoggy
and polluted.
Oh, is it?
You know what?
It's polluted everywhere right now.
Awful.
Half of Canada is under smoke,
forest fire.
Indonesia, the Philippines, portions of
Vietnam are all under smog and forest fire
from a massive forest fire in Malaysia.
Things have been burning for weeks and
weeks.
I can't believe it's reached this far.
Over water as well, like over vast oceans,
this smog and smoke is.
And then of course there's natural
pollution on top of everything else,
right?
If you're in Beijing or Moscow or
wherever.
Pretty brutal.
Yeah.
Okay.
Spend some personal time.
Something like that.
No,
I think it's good.
Okay.
This is a really important one.
Actually, I actually even have problems
answering this kind of question.
Because you don't want to sound too
arrogant by saying, oh, I have experience
and I have the knowledge, so generally my
estimates are accurate.
Well then, what did you do in the
beginning of your career?
Were you always inaccurate?
So, how do you estimate how long a front
end task or user story would take during
sprint planning?
Is it two story points, five story points?
It's a tough one to answer without seeming
arrogant because you know your stuff.
I've been lucky.
I don't, on the lower level technical
detail, I can't answer certain things,
but when it's an initiative, like let's
say it's two systems and you're
integrating it through some sort of
interface and you're going to be
exchanging data and then you're going to
update some workflows and user experience
and you got to the UI and UX updates and
then the complexity of how many data
elements there are and what information
you need to present.
And is there any complex technologies that
are being introduced that the team doesn't
know?
Like if the team knows it inside and out,
then it's going to be quick.
If they don't, it's going to be slow.
And generally any estimate you get from
them, double it, just so you're not wrong.
But yeah, it's a hard question.
It's a hard, hard question.
And it is, it's hard to estimate whether
you're in the beginning of your career or
you're a seasoned professional.
So,
yeah, the focus is interesting.
It says breaking tasks into even smaller
subcomponents, right?
So like if the user story is about
building an API, like at least the
blueprint of the API, well, you can
discuss what the subcomponents of the API
structure is, for example.
Not a bad approach.
Yeah.
Okay.
No worries.
Can you repeat, sorry?
To lobby for one's case.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's not really, yeah.
How you're answering it though doesn't
really correlate with how you estimate
like a technical feature or requirement.
I mean, you can lobby for your approach,
but are you basing it on your experience
or by breaking it up into smaller tasks
then you can estimate better based on
that?
So, yeah.
I understand what you're saying.
Okay.
I would describe it almost like you've
mentioned it, right?
So if a feature or if a feature or feature
defect or constant is
complicated, my approach is usually
breaking out the activity into smaller
technical tasks or subcomponents.
It is easier to estimate, is easier and
certainly more accurate to estimate
activities that are smaller
and concise.
It is easier and certainly more accurate
to estimate activities that are smaller
and concise rather
than an overall estimate on the main goal
of the request.
Okay.
Yeah, I know.
Yeah.
It is easier and certainly more accurate
to estimate the story points associated
with, there you go.
So that shows what you're talking about,
right?
So it is easier and certainly more
accurate to estimate the story points
associated with activities that are
smaller and more concise.
It is easier and increasingly
accurate to estimate the story points
associated with activities that are
smaller and more concise rather than an
overall estimate on, let's say,
the main goal of a request.
That actually sounds pretty good.
Clearly put more detail, but
because literally, and you know what?
This is what we actually do, Andrew,
when you think of it.
If you've got a really detailed user
story, right?
A lot of the times you do it, you even
generate tasks within JIRA and you
generate tasks according to the user
story.
It could also be an EPIC.
So if we are using real terminology using
JIRA, you can have an EPIC.
Within the EPIC, you have multiple user
stories and within those user stories,
they still can be complex to associate
tasks or you do a breakout of the
structure of the user story.
And that's how you, subcomponents,
that's how you really provide an overall
estimate that's going to be accurate,
right?
You don't, you know, you're not just going
to stick your finger up in the air and
say, this EPIC is going to take three
weeks.
Well, how do you know it's going to take
three weeks?
Well, that's based on the amount of story
points we've added up for all the user
stories that were put associated to this
EPIC and all the subcomponents within the
user stories.
And usually once you compile and tally all
those numbers, that gives you the main
estimate of the overall goal.
In each user story, there are
subcomponents or tasks that allow the
engineer, including myself, to provide the
lower level detailed estimate on how many
story points this would take.
By doing this, it increases the accuracy
of the estimate.
Yeah.
And I think if you're able just to talk
about the terminology and know it quite
well and talk about one approach that you
do, then it's more than sufficient.
Because it's asking, how do you estimate?
The interesting thing is, how do you
estimate?
It's not asking you, how do you estimate
and make sure it's accurate?
It just asks you, how do you estimate?
So I estimated JIRA using EPIC's user
stories and subcomponents or tasks and
hope that it's correct.
Right?
So funny enough, I've been blabbing to you
for the last five minutes about the
accuracy of the estimate.
And the question is, just how do you
estimate?
So although the words are not overly
complicated, but it's, you know,
this will be something that you can
transition into.
And if you learn these terms, which you
are, it's good.
It's about the approach.
Right?
So, yeah.
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
Absolutely.
I'll be interested to hear for the next
session where you see yourself growing
professionally over the next three or
three years.
The answer is, yeah, I want to go to an
international organization.
But yeah, that's the last one.
We managed to get through all of them,
all the tough ones, at least.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, of course.
And then have it all completely in Russian
too.
Or translate it into 50 languages.
No, but it's a good idea.
You know, transcription services of the
notes is fine.
But the reason that I type it out in real
time is so we can collaborate together on
what makes sense from an answer.
You know, if for transcription,
the problem with transcription is you get
all the writing at the end, unless it's
actually dictating and you see it type in
front of you.
Because there's two different approaches,
right?
Dictating software, which actually types
out what you say right in front of you on
the screen, or you get a summary of
everything that was said at the end of the
lesson, which is beneficial, but doesn't
allow us to collaborate in the way that we
do now.
Yeah, so just be aware of that if you
spend some time on automating what we're
doing.
And then, yeah, that would be good.
That would be cool.
Do you have a busy week ahead?
Or I shouldn't say busy week, a busy
weekend?
A pretty low key.
Okay.
I want to see how valuable Craig is.
So,
I've never—we don't even say hello to
Craig, eh?
We are rude, exceptionally rude.
Hello, Craig.
Craig, it's time for you to go to sleep.
You know, you don't say a damn thing,
so time for you to go sayonara.
Go sleep and do something useful for once
in your life.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks a lot, Andrew.
It was a lot of fun, as always.
So, have a nice weekend as well.